hi everybody welcome to you know what
your daily equation yes one more episode
of your daily equation and today I am
going to focus on one of the most
important equations in fundamental
physics it is the key equation of
quantum mechanics which I guess makes me
jump up in my seat right so it's one of
the key equations of quantum mechanics
many would say it is the equation of
quantum mechanics which is Schrodinger's
equation Schrodinger's equation so first
it's kind of nice to UM
have a picture of the guy himself the
man himself let's figure this out so let
me just bring this up on the screen so
they're nice handsome shot right of
Erlin Schrodinger who is the gentleman
that came up with an equation that
describes how quantum probability waves
evolve in time and just to get us all in
the in the right frame of mind let me
remind you of what we mean by a
probability wave we see one here
visualized with this blue undulating
surface and the intuitive idea is that
locations where the wave is big there is
a large probability to find the particle
let's say this is the probability wave
the wave function of an electron places
where the wave is small smaller
probability to find the electron and
places where the wave vanishes there's
no chance at all of finding the electron
there and this is how quantum mechanics
is able to make predictions but to make
predictions in any given situation you
need to know precisely what the
probability wave what the wave function
looks like and therefore you need an
equation that tells you how that shape
undulates changes over time so you can
for instance give the equation what the
wave shape looks like at any given
moment and then the equation turns the
cogs turns the gears that allows physics
dictate how that wave will change over
time so you need to know that equation
and that equation is Schrodinger's
equation in fact I can just
schematically show you that equation
right here there you see it writing
across the top and you see there's some
symbols in there and hopefully they are
familiar but if they're not that's okay
you can again take in this discussion or
any of these discussions I should say
discussions at any level that feels
comfortable to you if you want to follow
all the details you probably have to do
some further digging or maybe you have
some background but I have people
writing to me who say and I'm thrilled
to hear this is hey don't follow
everything that you're talking about in
these little episodes but people say hey
just enjoy seeing the symbols and just
getting a rough sense of the the
rigorous mathematics behind some of the
ideas that many people have heard about
for a long time but they've just never
seen the equations okay so what I'd like
to do is now give you some sense of
where Schrodinger's equation comes from
so I'm gonna have to do a little bit of
writing so let me bring excuse me
get in position here good I still in the
frame of the camera good bring my iPad
up on the screen and so the topic today
is Schrodinger's equation and it's not
an equation that you can derive from
first principles right it's an equation
that at best you can motivate now I'm
going to try to motivate the form of the
equation for you right now but
ultimately the relevance of an equation
in physics is governed or determined I
should say by the predictions it makes
and how
those predictions are two observations
so in the end of the day I could
actually just say here is Schrodinger's
equation let's see what predictions it
makes let's look at the observations
let's look at the experiments and if the
equation matches the observations if it
matches the experiments let me say hey
this is worthy of being viewed as a
fundamental equation of physics
regardless of whether I can derive it
from any earlier more fundamental
starting point but nevertheless it is a
good idea if you can get some intuition
for where the key equation comes from -
to gain that understanding so so let's
see how far we can get okay so in
conventional notation we often denote
the wavefunction of a single particle
I'm going to look at a single non
relativistic particle moving in one
spatial dimension I will generalize it
later on either in in this episode or a
subsequent one but let's stay simple for
now and so X represents the position and
T represents the time and again the
probability interpretation of this comes
from looking at sy XT it's norm squared
which gives us a nonzero number which we
can interpret as a probability if the
wave function is properly normalized
that is we ensure that the sum of all
the probabilities is equal to 1 if it
doesn't equal 1 we divide the
probability wave by say the square root
of that number in order that the new
renewal i's version of the probability
wave does satisfy the appropriate
normalization condition ok good now we
are talking about waves and whenever you
talk about waves the natural functions
to come into the story as the sine
function and say the cosine function
because you know these are the
prototypical wave-like shapes so it's
worthwhile that we focus upon those
in fact I'm going to introduce a
particular combination of those you may
recall either the I X is equal to cosine
X plus I sine X and you might say why am
i introducing that particular
combination well it will become clear a
little bit later on but for now you can
simply think of it as a convenient
shortcut allowing me to talk about sine
and cosine simultaneously rather than
having to think about them distinctly
think about them separately and you'll
recall that this particular formula is
one that we actually discussed in an
earlier episode that you can go back and
check that out or perhaps you already
know this wonderful fact but this
represents a wave in position space that
is a shape that looks like it has the
traditional ups and downs of the sine
and the cosine but we want a way that
changes in time and there's a
straightforward way to modify this
little formula to include that and let
me let me give you the standard approach
that we use so we often can say sine of
X and T in order that it has a wave
shape that changes through time e to the
I KX minus Omega T is the way we
describe the simplest version of such a
way if where does that come from well if
you think about it
think about even the I K X as a wave
shape of this sort forgetting about the
time part but if you include the time
part over here notice that as time gets
bigger let's say you focus on the peak
of this wave as time gets bigger X if
everything is positive its expression X
will need to get bigger in order that
the argument stays the same which would
mean that if we are focusing upon one
point the peak you want the value of
that peak to stay the same
so if tea gets bigger X gets bigger if X
gets bigger then this wave has moved
over and then this represents the amount
by which the wave has traveled over say
to the right so having this combination
over here KX minus Omega T is a very
simple straightforward way to ensure
that we're talking about a wave that not
only has a shape in X but actually
changes in time okay so that's just our
starting point a natural form of the
wave that we can take a look at and now
what I want to do is impose some physics
that's really just setting things up you
can think about that as the mathematical
starting point now we can introduce some
of the physics that we also have
reviewed in some earlier episodes and
again I'll try to keep this roughly
self-contained but I can't go over
everything so if you want to go back you
can refresh yourself on this beautiful
little formula that the momentum of a
particle in quantum mechanics is related
whoops I have to make this big is
related to the wavelength lambda of the
wave by this expression where H is
Planck's constant and therefore you know
you can write this as lambda equals H
over P now I'm reminding of this for a
particular reason which is in this
expression that we have over here we can
write down the wavelength in terms of
this coefficient K how can we do that
well imagine that X goes to X plus
lambda the wavelength and you can think
about that as sort of the the distance
if you will from one peak to another
wavelength lambda so if X goes to X plus
lambda we want the value of the wave to
be unchanged but in this expression here
if you replace X by X plus
but you will get in a difficult term
which will be of the form e to the I K
times lambda and if you want that to be
equal to one well you may recall this
beautiful result that we discussed that
e to the I pi equals minus 1 which means
e to the 2 pi I is the square of that
and that must be positive 1 so that
tells us that if K times lambda for
instance is equal to 2 pi then this
additional factor that we get by
sticking X equal X plus lambda in the
initial on Zots for the wave that will
be unchanged so therefore we get the
nice result that we can write say lambda
equals 2 pi over K and using that in
this expression over here we get say 2
pi over K equals H over P and I'm going
to write that as P equals H K over 2 pi
and I'm actually going to introduce a
little piece of notation that we
physicists are fond of using I'll define
a version of Planck's constant called H
bar the bar is a little bar going
through the top of the H I'll define
this as H over 2 pi because that
combination H over 2 pi crops up a lot
and with that notation I can write P
equals H Bar K so with P the momentum of
the particle I now have a relationship
between that physical quantity P and the
form of the wave that we have up here
for this guy here we now see is closely
related to the momentum of the particle
good
ok now let's turn to the other feature
of a particle that's
vital to have a handle on when you're
talking about particle motion which is
the energy of a particle now you will
recall and again we're just piecing
together a lot of separate individual
insights and using them to motivate the
form of the equation that we will get to
so you may recall say from the photo
electric effect that we had this nice
result that energy equals H Planck's
constant times frequency nu good now how
do we make use of that well in this part
of the form of the wave function you
have the time dependence and frequency
remember is how quickly the wave shape
is undulating through time so we can use
that to talk about the frequency of this
particular wave and I'll play the same
game that I just did but now I'll use
the T part instead of the X part namely
imagine replacing T goes to t plus 1
upon the frequency 1 upon the frequency
frequency again is cycles per time so
you turn that upside down and you've got
time per cycle so if you go through one
cycle that you take 1 over new say in
seconds now if that truly is one full
cycle again the wave should return to
the value that it had at time T okay now
does it well let's look upstairs so we
have this combination Omega times T so
what happens to Omega times T Omega
times T when you allow T to increase by
1 over nu will go to an additional
factor of Omega over nu you'll still
have the Omega T from you know this
first term over here but you have this
additional piece and we want that
additional piece to again not affect the
value of the way of ensuring that it has
returned to the value that it had
at time T and that will be the case if
for instance Omega over nu is equal to 2
pi because again we will have therefore
e to the I Omega over nu being e to the
I 2 pi which is equal to 1 no effect on
the value of the probability wave or the
wave function ok so from that then we
can write say nu is equal to 2 pi
divided by Omega and then using our
expression e equals H nu we can out
write this as 2 pi whoops I wrote this
the wrong way sorry about that you guys
need to correct me if I make a mistake
yeah let me just go back over here so
it's not as ridiculous so nu we learn is
equal to Omega over 2 pi that's what I
meant to write you guys didn't want to
correct me I know because you thought I
would be embarrassed but you should feel
free to jump in at any time if I make a
typographical error like that good ok so
so now we can go back to our expression
for energy which is H nu and write that
as H over 2 pi times Omega which is
h-bar Omega okay that is the counterpart
to the expression that we have above for
momentum being this guy over here now
these are two very nice formula because
they are taking this form of the
probability wave that we began with this
guy over here and now we have related
both K and Omega to physical properties
of the particle and because they're
related to physical properties of the
particle we can now use even more
physics to find a relationship between
those physical properties because energy
you will recall
I'm just doing you know non-relativistic
so I'm not using any relativistic ideas
or just standard you know high school
physics we can talk about energy say let
me begin with kinetic energy and I'll
include potential energy toward the end
but kinetic energy you'll recall is
one-half MV squared and using the non
relativistic expression P equals MV we
can write this as P squared over 2m okay
now why is that useful well we know that
P from the above this guy over here is
h-bar K so I can write this guys h-bar K
squared over 2m okay and this now we
recognize from the relationship that I
have right above over here let me change
colors is getting monotonous
so from this guy over here we have e is
h-bar Omega so we get h-bar Omega must
equal h-bar K squared divided by 2m now
that's interesting because if we now go
back why won't this thing scroll the way
there we go
so if we now remember that we have sine
of X and T is our little own so that
says e to the I KX minus Omega T we know
that ultimately we are going to be
shooting for a differential equation
which will tell us how the probability
wave changes over time and we have to
come up with a differential equation
which will require that the K term and
you make a turn term I should say stand
in this particular relationship H bar
Omega
H Bar K squared over 2m how can we do
that well pretty straightforward let's
starts taking
derivatives with respect to X first so
if you look at Desai DX what do we get
from that
well that's AI K from this guy over here
and then what remains because the
derivative of an exponential is just the
exponential modulo the coefficient in
front pulling down this would be I K
times psy of X and T okay but this has a
K squared so let's do one more
derivative so D - sigh DX squared well
what will that do is bring down one more
factor of I K so we get I K square times
psy of X and T in other words minus K
squared times I of X and T since I
squared is equal to minus 1 okay that's
good so we have our K squared in fact if
we want to have exactly this term in
here that's not hard to arrange right so
all I need to do is put a minus H bar
squared oh no again running out of
battery this thing runs out of battery
so quickly I am really gonna be upset if
this thing dies before I finished so
here I'm in this situation again but I
think we have enough juice to make it
through anyway so I'm just gonna put a
minus H bar squared over 2m in front of
my D to psy.d x squared why do I do that
because when I take this minus sign
together with this minus sign and this
pre factor this indeed will give me H
Bar K squared over 2m times sine of X
and T all right so that's nice I have
the right hand side of this relationship
over here now let me take time
derivatives why time derivatives because
if I want to get an Omega in this
expression the only way to get that is
by taking a time derivative so let's
just take a look at change color here to
distinguish it so decide DT what is
active
well again the only non-trivial part is
the coefficient of the T that will pull
down so I get minus I Omega psy of X and
T again the exponential when you take
the derivative of it gives itself back
up to the coefficient of the argument of
the exponential and this almost looks
like that I can make it precisely in H
bar Omega simply by hitting this with a
minus IH bar in front and by hitting it
with an IH bar in front the or a minus
IH bar did I do this correctly here no I
don't need a minus here what am i doing
let me just get rid of this guy over
here yes so if I have my IH bar here and
I multiply that by my - come on
- ma there we go said the I and the - I
will multiply together to give me a
factor of 1 so I'll just have an H bar
Omega sy of X and T now that's very nice
so I have my H bar Omega in fact I can
squeeze this down a little bit kena
no I can't unfortunately so I have my H
bar Omega here and I got that from my IH
bar Deeside DT and I have my H Bar K
squared over 2m and I got that guy from
my - H bar squared over 2m t - sy DX
squared so I can impose this equality by
looking at the differential equation I
will let me change color because now
we're sort of getting to the end here
what should I use something a nice dark
blue so I have I h-bar Desai DT equals
minus H bar squared over 2m d - sy DX
squared and lo and behold this is
Schrodinger's equation for the non
relativistic motion in one spatial
dimension
there's only an X ther of a particle
that is not being acted upon by a force
what do I mean by that is well you may
recall if we go back over here I said
that the energy that I was focusing my
attention on over here
it was the kinetic energy and if a
particle is not being acted upon by a
force that will be its full energy but
in general if a particle is being acted
upon by a force given by a potential and
that potential V of X gives us
additional energy from from the outside
right it's not intrinsic energy that
comes from the motion of the particle
it's coming from the particle being
acted upon by some force gravitational
force electromagnetic force whatever how
would you include that in this equation
well it's pretty straightforward we
dealt with kinetic energy as the full
energy and that's what gave us this
fella over here this came from P squared
over 2m
but kinetic energy should now go to
kinetic energy plus potential energy
which can depend on where the particle
is located so the natural way to include
that then is simply to modify the
right-hand side so we have IH bar d sy
DT equals minus H bar squared over 2m d2
sy DX squared plus just add in this
additional piece of e of x times I of X
and that is the full form of the
nonrelativistic Schrodinger equation for
particle being acted upon by a force
whose potential is given by this
expression V of X moving in one spatial
dimension so you know it's it's a bit of
it's bit of a slog to get the
form of the equation again that should
at least give you a feel for where the
pieces come from but let me finish by
now just showing you why it is that we
take this equation seriously and the
reason is well actually let me show you
one final thing let's say I am looking
and I'll just again be schematic here so
imagine that I look at say size squared
at a given moment in time and let's say
it has some particular shape as a
function of X these Peaks right and
these some smaller locations and so
forth are giving us the probability of
finding the particle at that location
which means if you run the same
experiment over and over and over again
and say measure the particles position
at the same amount of T the same amount
of elapsed time from some initial
configuration and you simply make a
histogram of how many times you find the
particle at one location or another and
say a thousand runs of the experiment
you should find that those histograms
fill out this probability profile and if
that's the case then the probability
profile is actually accurately
describing the results of your
experiments so let me show you that just
to know again it's totally secure matic
let me just bring this guy up over here
okay so the blue curve is the norm
squared of a probability wave at a given
moment in time and let's just run this
experiment of finding the particles
position in many many many runs of the
experiment and I'm gonna put an X every
time I find the particle at one value of
position versus another and you see over
time the histogram is indeed filling out
the shape of the probability wave that
is the norm squared of the quantum
mechanical wave function of course that
is just you know a simulation a
rendition but if you look at real world
the probability profile given to us by
the wavefunction that solves
Schrodinger's equation does indeed
describe the probability distribution of
where you find the particle on many many
runs of identically prepared experiments
and that ultimately is why we take the
Schrodinger equation
seriously the motivation I gave you
should give you a feel for where the
various pieces of the equations come
from but ultimately it is an
experimental issue as to which equations
are relevant to real-world phenomena and
the Schrodinger equation by that measure
has come through over the course of
almost a hundred years with flying
colors okay that's all that I wanted to
say today Schrodinger's equation the key
equation of quantum mechanics that
should give you a feel for where it
comes from and ultimately why we believe
it describes reality until next time
this is your daily equation take care